no matter how lost how confused how
alone or how desperate you may be or
feel
there is always hope there is always
help if you seek it what I'm saying is
change is possible transformation is
within your grasp always
and for so many reasons I've come to
believe that it's your Birthright to
grow it's something that's imprinted on
our DNA it is our mandate but there is a
caveat and it's a powerful one at that
and it's captured in this saying that's
often repeated within 12-step
communities and it goes like this
change isn't for those who need it it's
for those who want it it's all about
willingness change is always within your
grasp if you can summon the willingness
to ask for it and again and most
importantly receive it when given